users you don't want and this one was
Stannis yeah this was fun yeah when
you're just getting started many
startups will take every user they can
get they have a strong idea of a problem
and they want to attract as many users
with that problem as possible
unfortunately when you open up the barn
doors you get all sorts of people with
all sorts of problems
some of them will try to hijack your
product to solve a problem you didn't
intend to solve by and large these
hijacks hijackers are users you do not
want when is this happen to you I mean
justin.tv was by definition hijacked
yeah like we built a product to allow
people to livestream their lives and
within a year it was being used to
stream copper and content around the
world
absolutely hijacked from and and and
what's interesting is that I'm a little
afraid of my phrasing here I I wish I
didn't say that these hijack users are
not are not users you want because it
turns out that like sometimes they are
yeah it turns out that like you know the
reason why we even had an inkling to do
twitch was because some percentage of
the hijack users were video gamers and
like it turns out that that could have
been a much bigger community if we if we
helped it and then eventually became one
so this kind of like users using your
product for a whole variety of things I
like to think about it more like on a
spectrum mm-hmm like there's the user
who's using your product as intended
yeah great makes feel good maybe there's
a business there maybe there's right
there's the user who's using your
product in interesting ways with
potential yeah right yeah study those
users those users are very important
video gamers are justin.tv there are
users who are using your product with
ways that it's extremely clear to you
that there isn't long term value even if
there is short-term value right I'd
argue that those were the copper and in
streamers on justin.tv there's a short
term value because we can monetize with
ads and so once over the long term we
weren't really creating value and then
they're like hi
Jack users I'd argue like those are
users who are using your product and
they're creating no value and they're
probably actively do you like decreasing
your value they're there they're harming
your network right and like for us you
know that would be people like you know
some people's dreams like pretty
horrible things on justin.tv right like
that was that was not good and so um
what's interesting is that now when I
talk to startups at YC they don't know
how to recognize these hijack users and
just kick them out mmm and like they
kind of like no one no one talks about
these people they always talk about like
everyone before them yeah right we're
just like those of uses that have some
value and no talk about the highe just
users and it's like if you can identify
the hijack users you need to kick them
out like they're actually going to hurt
you more than they're gonna help you and
so I think this is important and I think
that like it's not that the hayek users
have like bad intentions even um they
can some do but some it's just they want
to use your prod to do what they want to
do and that is literally going to hurt
your business there are some things that
like if people do on your platform it
hurts your business how would you how
would you classify someone who just
takes up all the customer support time
it depends on how much revenue they're
generating yeah right like I'd argue
that if they are generating enough
revenue to justify that support time
great yeah if you have a free product
not so much yeah so much probably right
especially if you're not learning if
they're taking up a bunch of your
support time but you're learning and
like you're actually improving your
product because of it great but like for
example like let's see I'll create a
hypothetical example without my head
right imagine that I'm the beginning of
Airbnb someone wanted to use Airbnb to
host like drug parties right like a
legal drug bar is a crack parties and
they thought of these Airbnb ziz like
mobile crack dens right well let's think
about this for a second like so on one
hand right
they are paying yeah I mean they're
paying for the big apartment it's paying
for the nice places yeah right yeah they
got money all right interesting the
other hand they're probably destroying
this apartment doing something highly
illegal
getting the police called on them like
deadheaded it out right and it's like
these are hijack users like these are
not the types of people you want and
like you can be a hijack user and
there's still some positive yeah but it
says like if there's like way too much
negative it's not worth the positive now
and that's actually where I see a lot I
actually see it a lot where it's like
the high tech users paying so you'll
feel bad cuz when the hydrogen she's not
paying usually you feel less bad taking
on here yeah when they're paying you're
like well but they're paying right and
and you and it's like no you just okay
come out yeah especially in the context
of like you have these metrics you want
to hit and you're like yeah right oh my
god like like this is real this is stop
it's like shut it down
yeah yeah and you end it in a nice clean
way by saying by focusing on solving one
problem really well you're betting on
making a small amount of people very
happy if you let any user that walks in
the door if the product roadmap you're
going to end up doing shitty job at so
half solving a lot of problems yeah I
mean to be clear with this ending my
whole goal is that like like I said
there's like this spectrum of
potentially useful users yeah my whole
goal is like don't let the hijack users
steer your product roadmap totally like
the it's really totally ok if you want
to explore some of those use cases that
are not these case that you thought that
are still use cases that like could be
good for you huh then it's a totally ok
to explore to experiment so and so forth
but it's like don't let your app like
don't let the crack den guys on Airbnb
control the product or a math for air
B&B right and suggest two features that
they like right not where you want I
mean this is sort of the mentality it's
like at the end of the day you have to
have some opinion about your product you
can't just be like I don't know if the
markets gonna take it wherever the
customers take it wherever yes it's been
really hard to build product without
some opinion yeah
you